a private burial was held Tuesday for
former Russian mercenary boss ye evgeny
pagosian nearly a week after he and nine
others died in a suspicious plane crash
north of Moscow security was tight at
the St Petersburg Cemetery where the
ceremony took place members of the
Russian national guard were posted
around the facility to keep the public
out Russian media say the family wished
the event to stay private and stark
contrast to a separate ceremony in which
one of pagosian's Wagner group deputies
was buried memorials for those killed in
last week's crash have been growing in
several Russian cities
seems pretty evident what happened here
that as the president said that said
this recently I believe as early as last
week that and I quote there's not much
that happens in Russia that Putin is not
behind uh and if it's uh if this is what
it seems uh to be this this what is uh
certainly was not uh just predictable
but it was predicted if I should I
should say uh we all we all know that
the Kremlin has a long history of
killing its opponents uh that is the
history of of the Kremlin and if we take
a step back if we look back for a second
all of this happened because of
dysfunction inside Russia a Russian
warlord himself a cold-blooded killer a
cold-blooded murderer became so
frustrated by the way that the Russian
government was waging its unprovoked war
against Ukraine that he criticized
Russia's failing policies and so now two
months later after he he struck that
deal he's been killed so um you know
it's very clear the it's pretty evident
what happened here